hair trends as quickly as they appear
they disappear except for this one men's
powdered wigs a trend that strangely
lasted a century and had close ties not
to fashion but to an std
[Music]
powdered wigs also known as perux were
all the rage in the 1700s they were the
hot item for aristocratic men but it
wasn't a stylistic choice rather men
mostly wore the wigs because of syphilis
starting in 1580 syphilis outbreak
spread to become one of the worst
epidemics to ever hit europe on par with
the black death there were no
antibiotics to combat the disease and so
victims faced blindness dementia hair
loss and even open sores
at that time going bald was considered
quite embarrassing as syphilis spread
the wig makers got busy they created
beautiful baroques coated with powder
and even scented with lavender to hide
any unpleasant smells at this point the
wigs were not yet considered stylish but
all that changed in 1655 when louis xiv
started going bald clearly the king of
france couldn't be seen without hair so
he did what any man of that day would he
bought a wig well actually he hired 48
of the best wig makers to create him a
custom wig five years later the king of
england did the same thing shortly
thereafter aristocrats followed suit and
thus the term bigwig was born
you